[Music]
it's been six months since my first
visit to Brixton prison while I'm
confident our lemon treacle slice could
be a best-seller so far I've been unable
to find a major outlet it's a 24/7 worry
[Music]
even while I'm at the day job I'm very
busy
but I just can't stop thinking about
because bad boy bakery is trickling
along so what I haven't got is a heavy
weight business a big coffee house a
chain and now one of the very top if I
can't find a major retailer willing to
sell the slice the bad boys bakery is
going out of business
it's not going to last much longer
unless I land a bloody big coffee change
the fast-growing UK coffee shop industry
is worth around five billion pounds a
year I want us to get a slice of the
action but so far the response has been
lukewarm Casta an extremely positive
feedback from the head of food however
once it went to the senior directors for
approval they decided it would be wrong
to proceed with a meeting
I'm afraid since we spoke to waitress
cafe they also turned us down due to the
conflict with Heston I've employed a
coffee industry expert who has been
pushing the slice with Kathy Nero but
there's a general concern that the
recipe might be too sweet hi helen is
Gordon yeah we've come on leaps and
bounds so I haven't even had a chance to
show them Squires and that's like you
know Chelsea Football Club versus
[ __ ] Stenhousemuir I would appreciate
that
the Squires they've got outlets in
[ __ ] New Zealand
[ __ ] me New Zealand there's more [ __ ]
sheep than there is coffee bus caffeine
arrow are concerned about the product
and our ability to deliver a big order
while I need to keep pushing for a
meeting in the meantime I'm pressing on
with plans to develop the marketing it's
not just the taste that's important to
the slighty success it is vital that the
public buy into the idea behind it how
are we gonna sell that bar how we going
to market it yeah I need help
because this has to be per cross yeah
the right way and you don't get a second
chance of this